[SINGING IN LATIN]
LARRY ARNN: The Psalmist
writes, "unless the Lord
builds the house, those who
build it labor in vain."
We have cause to think that this
is the largest classical chapel
built in 70 years.
The question is not
why have we built this.
When you walk in here,
don't you look up and think
of the ultimate things?
The answer to that
question is obvious.
The hard question is,
why have others not?
I think it is a turning away
from things that are beautiful,
which means necessarily then
also things that are true
and things that are good.
When the truth and
the beauty and good
are gone, then, of
course, all reasons
that demand we strive to become
good human beings are gone.
It is actually the purpose of
the activity of the College
to explain and
understand all that.
And that activity goes on
intensely now for 175 years.
CLARENCE THOMAS: This is
a very special occasion,
175th anniversary of
Hillsdale and the dedication
of this beautiful chapel.
The chapel's enduring beauty
highlights the transcendence,
sovereignty, and
the grace of God.
It truly illustrates
how architectural design
can reflect the character of God
and evoke a sense of reverence
for His majesty.
PATRICK SAJAK:
You're going to hear
a lot in the coming
months about the four
purposes of this college--
learning, character,
faith, and freedom.
These are the principles of
education here at Hillsdale,
have been for 175
years, and we hope
it will be another 175 years.
LARRY ARNN: We live
in an age of confusion
that has become dangerous
threatening tyranny.
The only thing ultimately that
can dispel it is understanding.
This college was
born 175 years ago
to give that
understanding wherever
anybody wanted to learn.
You and God have given us
the means to make that big.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]